αστημομική νένα ποόλαν πααράδειγμα θα ποονόματα αλλά να πολναν παράδειγμα και ας με τι αψεύσειξέρουσεν
και πια που ήταν τηλεδί άσκεψη προινεί η εσία της αστυνομίας και επικεφαλίς λέει πέστε
στα κομματικά πρόσωπα που μου τηλεφωνούν καθημερινός για τις προαγωϊές σας να σταματήσουν να μου
τηλεφωνο δεν πρόκεισα ν ανεκτόνα μου τηλεφώνηση άλλον κόμματικός τελεγχος για προαγωρίές αξωματικό αυτόν ας
αν μεφισβητήσουν μεί τεέσες σας να αρτουμε στο ελτιον ιδήσευμο να πο ότιο ονόματα τω
να πω και την τηλεδιάσκεψη τούτον της αδείχνει σας δείχνει ότι πίνουν μετες ποείνες με
στην αστυνομία να μείνουν έξω να μείνουν έξω η αστυνομία υπέρθυν για την ασφάλειας σας
αφήστε να προαχθούν οι καλύτεροι αφήστε να τοποθεστηθούν αυτή αυτή που πρεκεί που πρέπει και
αφήστετα ροσφαθκα νν καιρος για τα κόμματα τώρα νανεγατώντα με στην αστυνομία ένν νο καιρωσί
ήταν παγιά των το πράγμα τώρα πρέπει να σταματήσει και οφίλη να σταματης έθουμε πρόβλημαθσίτώ
τρα αστό τι μόνη της αστυνομίας βρίσκονται δύ στελέχει τα οποία ήταν σε νευραδικά πόστα
ε πότα κλειδιά σε μεγάλες υποθέσεις θεωρείς ότι κάπως αλλάζει και κάνει λίγον και πιο
επιχειρησια και την όλη κατάσταση ο ένας ήταν της διερεύνησης ο αλλός ος περιισακός αποτελέσματα
κουμι πρέπει να κάμουγλί ώρα αλλαγές αγιώς δεν πέζζει όλον το παευθόν τους αν έχουν
πάλμαρές σα βιογραφικό για αν έχουν δυνατότητες εξαιτείας αυτό που πέρασαν στην καρικέ να τους
ενέναν κεφάλειο το αθα πράξει στηνον αποκάσι ς πάσει στην καρέκλα ενάλλον κεφάι ούλοι είχα
δυνατοίδες ολι είχαν γνώσεις ολοι είχαν δεξιότηδες επατήσαν τα κουν πια ναδείξει ανπατήσει τα κουμπια
να κάνι ση ναφανούν στα αποτέλεσμα αγιώσουμε το παλμαρε και ο βιογραφικό και τον καλύτρο
πέχτι να φέρουν στην κύπρο να πεξεποδόσφορο ποπραμα